we are now doing a study that addresses
the global values of fisheries
recreation tourism and shoreline
protection these results of this
analysis they have just been finalized
have just being produced but what this
kind of analysis show using different
methodologies is that some areas are
really have very very high values in
which we want to focus our efforts on
and and that has you know some
implications for policies in terms of
let's say in the case of Fisheries where
the benefits go and where you know
whether local people are getting those
benefits valuation remains a fairly
controversial issue and as you all know
but one that is extremely necessary
because when you make decisions you
really rely on information there there's
no perfect information there is no
perfect world but you really really have
to have a minimum amount of information
so we do evaluation at a global level to
have a good picture of how you know what
the main areas and oftentimes weird well
Vince to some specific areas to look
some specific countries to see you know
what the values are for the local
economy but the main point of this is
just to tell you that this is all very
well an interesting but you know what is
the utimate goal what is a utimate go of
evaluation exercise its decision making
and how do you go about you know what
kind of information and what kind of
decision-making what kind of indicators
can help us to really incorporate the
natural capital values into these
indicators that are more widely accepted
you know we economies ecologists we
often provide single you know point site
analysis or global analysis that I just
described but they remain what this may
remain a study that was done that showed
the value of the
is it a system services provided by that
biome is such the challenge now is how
to move on into this macro economic
indicator that will tell you that the
you know the natural capital values need
to be incorporate so we get more and
more aware of how resources are being
degraded and we get more and more aware
of our dependence on natural capital a
couple of years ago a colleague and I
did a review of our initiatives on
ecosystem services and payment for
existing services schemes around the
world and we really found some very
interesting lessons and insights from
our portfolio first we really realize
that we really need more science we
really many of these schemes that you
come across are you know a lot of them
are based on assumption you see that in
the literature so you really need to
address more you know the issues of
provision benefits additionality and we
certainly hope that the exercise we did
can shed light into that we need more
spatially explicit tools I think they
are becoming more and more available but
they're still fairly sophisticated in
fairly complex we need to make sure that
we can using those tools convey the
message in a clear compelling way you
know with with the robust science that
we want to see but in a way that allows
for the impact to be more easily
observed we need to really care and
address social economic and ecological
context I think we as scientists we very
much focus on the biophysical and
economic side but not so much on the
social i think parts of authority
approaches have proven to be critical